I've seen some conservatives making fun
of this and calling it woke it's another
woke inclusive PC thing is what some are
saying and and I'll admit that in the
first moment after I saw this headline I
almost had that reaction because I saw
the term inclusive Barbie doll and my
first instinctive reaction is to roll my
eyes because 99.9 of the time it's going
to be something stupid but then there's
the 0.1 of the time when it's actually
something good and this is the point one
percent we don't want to be like dogs
you know barking whenever we hear a car
in the driveway no matter who's driving
it we want to have discernment right and
and we should have it here
Down syndrome people
really do need to be included we need we
do need inclusivity campaigns for them
because Down syndrome people especially
children are being excluded from society
in the most violent and bloody ways
they're being exterminated by the
abortion industry